[Musique]
le groupe les républicains au Sénat sur
ce texte assurance chômage a obtenu en
commission en mix paritaire des avancées
sur trois domaines le premier nous avons
rappelé que la gestion de l'assurance
chômage c'était le sujet des partenaires
sociaux le gouvernement voulait les
évincer nous avons remis au coeur du
système le deuxième concerne les
collectivités locales il y a des
demandeurs d'emploi maintenant qui sont
des anciens fonctionnaires il y avait un
vrai sujet que nous avons traité et
enfin le troisième qui nous ramène à ce
qu'est l'assurance chômage qui est un
système assurantiel je rappelle que
l'assurance chômage donne droit à
l'allocation de retour à l'emploi dès
lors qu'on est privé de façon
involontaire d'emploi et nous l'avons
rappelé à travers finalement deux
articles 1 lorsqu'on fait un CDD et
qu'on refuse de CDI nous n'avons plus le
droit à la location de retour à l'emploi
et de lorsqu'on est en intérim et que
l'on refoule refuse de CDI nous avons
pris le droit à la location de retour à
l'emploi ce système assurantiel c'est il
est essentiel que nous puissions appeler
ce principe là et je le dis très
ouvertement le gouvernement évoque le
fait que de ces dispositifs sont
difficiles à mettre en oeuvre moi je
veux dire au gouvernement il est de
votre responsabilité de mettre en
application les textes de loi et nous y
verrons dans le cadre du contrôle de
notre pouvoir de contrôle en tant que
parlementaire
[Musique]